Les oiseaux chantent.
...
Musique douce
-La première fois
que j'ai rencontré Ghulam Ali,
il venait de traduire en langue dari
"Le Dormeur du val"
d'Arthur Rimbaud.
Le vieil homme lisait des poèmes
pour oublier la guerre.
Lui et 24 autres anciens interprètes
afghans de l'armée françaises
vivaient dans la ville de Laon,
dans l'est de la France.
Ces interprètes
venus des quatre coins
de l'Afghanistan
avaient travaillé aux côtés
des soldats français
contre les Talibans
entre 2001 et 2014.
Tous avaient été rapatriés
avec leurs familles à Laon.
Tous tentaient de trouver leur place
dans cette ville
située dans la diagonale du vide.
-Nous, on est venus comme...
Je peux...
...utiliser une expression :
comme un champignon
dans la forêt, là.
Sifflement d'oiseau
...
Quand on a quitté l'Afghanistan,
on a préparé des bagages,
à peu près 6 bagages, 6 sacs.
En plus, les dimensions
étaient données par l'ambassade.
Il ne fallait pas dépasser de ça.
C'était 70 sur 50.
Donc c'est ça,
en respectant tout ça,
qu'est-ce qu'il faut mettre ?
Une vie de 40 ans...
Alors il faut la mettre
dans les sacs.
Ca ne rentrera jamais.
Des cloches sonnent.
...
Les enfants aussi, ils avaient
des souvenirs, dans la maison,
dans les pièces.
Alors ils ont gardé leurs jouets,
et j'ai rangé
leurs jouets et j'ai numéroté.
J'ai mis que dans ce sac-là,
il y a "ça", "ça", "ça", "ça".
"Ca, c'est ton sac. Tu viendras,
un jour, et tu vas le récupérer.
"Tu récupèreras tous tes jeux."
Et là, en réalité, je me suis dit :
"Tu sais que non.
"Ce n'est pas un aller-retour,
mais c'est un aller sans retour."
L'oiseau siffle.
...
Dans l'avion : stress
et les questions
que je disais tout à l'heure :
"Comment je fais ? Je vais où ?
Je serai accueilli comment ?"
Tout ça, c'est des questions
que même les enfants
et même mon épouse me disaient :
"Alors, comment on fait ?
"On a abandonné notre pays,
une belle vie,
"et est-ce qu'on aura
l'occasion d'en avoir ?"
Ah, mais je disais -
pour la calmer, toujours, toujours -
"Il faut perdre quelque chose
pour avoir autre chose.
"Vous avez perdu la guerre
et l'insécurité,
"maintenant,
vous allez vivre en paix.
"C'est pas grave,
si c'est une tente."
Musique douce
Cavalier.
...
-Franchement,
je ne connaissais pas beaucoup,
ni la culture française,
ni d'autres choses
par rapport à la France.
Parce que j'ai entendu que...
J'avais entendu
qu'il y a la liberté,
la fraternité, l'égalité
et que tout ce qu'on veut,
on peut le faire, en France.
C'est ça, que j'avais entendu
quand j'étais en Afghanistan
et quand je suis arrivé ici,
en France,
j'ai vu que c'était bien ça.
Les femmes et les hommes
sont mélangés.
Ils vont au bar
et ils boivent du café
et puis, ils discutent et tout ça.
Une fois arrivé sur le territoire
français, j'ai vu.
En fait, ça m'a choqué un peu,
mais pas beaucoup.
Ca m'a choqué un peu et puis voilà.
Depuis 6 ans, j'ai l'habitude,
maintenant, voilà.
Au début, nous avions espoir
de rester en Afghanistan.
On ne pensait jamais
venir en France,
parce que c'était notre pays.
On ne savait pas
que la situation sécuritaire
allait se dégrader, en fait,
pour les interprètes
ou ceux qui ont travaillé
avec l'armée française.
Musique douce
...
-Depuis que je me souviens,
il y avait la guerre.
L'arrivée des Russes,
des Soviétiques,
le djihad, la résistance
contre les Soviétiques,
l'arrivée des moudjahidines,
la guerre civile.
Il y avait tout le temps
une guerre, en fait.
Et la guerre,
elle a apporté un malheur
aux générations des Afghans.
Des oiseaux chantent.
...
Les Afghans, ils sont pauvres.
Ils sont satisfaits
avec un morceau de pain,
une assiette d'épinards,
et ça passe.
Les Français, ils n'ont pas
ce niveau économique.
Ils ont beaucoup plus
de pouvoir d'achat.
Ils vont en pique-nique,
ils vont en Egypte, à l'étranger.
Ils profitent de la vie,
ils cherchent des richesses.
Ils cherchent des plaisirs
dans la vie,
alors que les Afghans, les pauvres,
ils veulent être vivants
et avoir de quoi manger
et qu'ils soient capables
d'aller à l'école,
et au moins, ne pas avoir la guerre
et des obus, des CHICOM
qui tombent sur leur maison.
C'est ça, la différence
entre vivre et être vivant.
Les Afghans veulent être vivants,
mais les Français,
ils veulent vivre.
Brouhaha indistinct
...
Les enfants bavardent.
Musique mélancolique
...
-Laon...
C'est la meilleure partie de ma vie
parce que
quand les Talibans
sont arrivés à Kaboul,
c'est la France qui nous a sauvés.
C'était dangereux pour mon mari,
pour mes enfants et pour moi
parce que tout le monde dit
que vous êtes
des espions de la France.
Ils disaient :
"Ton mari aussi,
il travaille avec les étrangers,
avec les Français, et toi aussi,
avec les Français."
A cause de ça, nous étions obligés
de venir en France,
pour sauver notre vie.
Musique nostalgique
...
-Je connais la guerre, j'ai goûté.
Ca a été douloureux, en fait.
J'ai participé
à beaucoup de missions de combat,
des patrouilles, et cetera.
Environ 150-200 missions...
...missions sur le terrain
et c'était dangereux, oui, bien sûr.
-L'interprète jouait
un rôle primordial.
C'était un point de contact
entre l'armée française
et la population afghane.
C'était toujours l'interprète
qui rentrait dans le village
en premier.
Après, le deuxième,
c'était le chef de section.
C'était le lieutenant,
le sergent-chef ou l'adjudant-chef
qui se renseignaient
concernant les Talibans et tout ça.
C'étaient souvent les interprètes
qui apprenaient la culture afghane
aux armées de l'OTAN,
aux armées françaises.
Sans interprète,
l'armée ne pouvait rien faire.
Jusqu'à 2008,
la situation sécuritaire
était calme, en Afghanistan.
Même l'armée française sortait
sans gilets pare-balles,
sans VAB, sans FAMAS.
C'est après 2008
que la situation sécuritaire
a commencé à se détériorer,
de jour en jour.
Quand il y avait
des opérations comme ça,
quand on sortait du camp,
on était obligés de se défendre.
C'était souvent le capitaine
ou le colonel
qui nous fournissait les armements.
On rentrait dans le village
parce qu'on avait
les mêmes vêtements
que les soldats français,
les gilets pare-balles.
Personne ne pouvait différencier
entre les interprètes
et les soldats français.
Et ils nous tiraient, en fait.
Ils nous tiraient dessus,
de la fenêtre,
de la maison et tout ça.
On était obligés de se défendre.
On n'était pas bien formés,
mais on pouvait tirer,
on pouvait tirer.
-On nous a tirés dessus.
Je n'avais pas d'arme.
Je n'insistais pas
pour avoir une arme.
Ce qu'on m'a dit, je l'ai fait,
mais j'ai été affecté
en tant que PCRL,
personnes civiles recrutées
en local, personnes locales.
Je n'étais pas soldat,
mais interprète civil.
Quand on m'a donné le FAMAS,
je l'ai pris.
Sinon, je n'ai pas insisté.
Il rit.
-Ouais, ça, c'est Uzbin.
-C'était à Uzbin, oui.
-Oui, c'était Uzbin.
-Attends, il a donné
le certificat...
-Ah ! Ouais, ouais, ouais...
Ils rient.
-Oui, c'est les souvenirs
qui restent.
On est des êtres humains.
Ce n'est pas vrai,
quand on dit
que les Afghans sont métalliques
et qu'ils n'ont pas peur.
Nous, pour ça, on a un proverbe.
Propos en langue étrangère
"Chacun a peur, le soir.
"Certains le disent,
certains le cachent."
Un bébé babille.
...
-Quand on est
en situation de guerre,
on voit beaucoup de choses.
Il y a des soldats afghans,
des soldats français,
qui sont déjà blessés,
morts, à côté de toi.
Pour nous, moralement,
c'était très,
très difficile d'oublier.
Si c'est un soldat,
ils ont étudié ou sont entraînés
pour que,
quand il y a quelque chose
qui arrive, il faut l'oublier,
mais les interprètes, nous,
c'est un cauchemar
pour tout le monde,
pour tous les interprètes.
-Je voulais démissionner. Après...
Après, quand il n'y avait pas
de conflit,
je pensais que ce ne serait
peut-être pas répété, voilà.
Et puis, d'un côté,
le capitaine, le lieutenant
de l'armée française aussi,
ils m'encourageaient à travailler,
ils me donnaient du courage.
"C'est fini, il n'y a pas
d'autre attaque..."
-Il n'y a pas de guerre à gagner.
Ce n'est pas la guerre
du courage ou des sabres.
C'est les armements
chauds automatiques
qui fonctionnent avec la puissance
du gaz, de la poudre.
Ca n'a rien à voir avec le courage,
une guerre gagnée
ou une guerre perdue.
C'est les Américains qui gagnent.
C'est le monde entier qui paye.
Musique pesante
...
-Fin 2014...
Oui, 2014,
le général, le général français,
il a fait ses adieux,
il a remercié la coopération,
il a fait son discours.
Moi, j'étais honoré
de faire l'interprétation
de "goodbye party", quoi,
on peut dire.
"Nous quittons aujourd'hui
cette académie
"avec une émotion certaine.
Vous le savez,
"la France ne fournira pas
de soldats
"pour la prochaine mission de
l'OTAN en Afghanistan.
"Mais la France restera à vos côtés.
Donc, après le départ
des Français,
les premières cibles,
c'était les interprètes.
Les interprètes
qui ont travaillé avec l'OTAN,
c'était les cibles,
après les officiers et la police.
Il y avait 50 000 afghanis,
pour un interprète.
Pour la tête d'un interprète.
La récompense.
Parce qu'ils disaient
que les interprètes étaient
la langue, les pieds,
les mains
et même le cerveau de l'OTAN,
ou même des militaires français
ou bien étrangers.
-Il y avait une grosse bombe,
un engin explosif,
qui était dissimulé
derrière la maison.
C'était à une heure du matin
que ça a explosé.
Il y avait trois chambres,
ça s'est effondré.
Il y avait des briques,
des décombres partout.
Nous étions légèrement blessés,
pas beaucoup,
et c'était...
J'étais choqué, en fait.
Je n'avais pas d'autre solution
et puis j'étais obligé
de commencer
à faire la manifestation
et de réunir tous mes collègues
au parc,
pour trouver une solution
et sauver notre vie.
-On a donné les dossiers.
Et la réponse, le dernier jour,
le courrier nous a dit
que c'était négatif.
Notre dossier ne répondait pas
aux critères
de la demande d'asile
ou d'être rapatrié,
ramené en France.
On ne répondait pas aux critères.
Je ne sais pas quels critères.
-J'ai décidé d'aller voir
directement
un attaché militaire
à l'ambassade de France.
Nous avons bien expliqué
que voilà, nous sommes en danger.
Pourquoi certains de nos collègues
sont déjà partis en France
et pourquoi nous ne pouvons pas
bénéficier de la protection ?
Il nous a fait partir, en fait,
de l'ambassade,
en disant que voilà...
"Lequel d'entre vous
est mort pour la France ?"
La même phrase.
Et puis...
Nous sommes retournés chez nous.
Musique douce
...
-C'est la question que posaient même
les officiers afghans :
"Vous restez, vous ne partez pas
avec les Français ?
"On vous a abandonnés ?
Qu'est-ce que vous faites ?
"On peut vous recruter ici ?"
Les collègues du travail,
les Français, nous disaient :
"Là, vous serez abandonnés.
On part d'ici définitivement.
"Vous serez comme les harkis."
Pareil, ce sera répété
encore une fois.
-Nous, les Afghans, on fait pas ça.
Facilement, on serre pas la main,
ou on fait pas l'amitié,
mais quand on le fait,
c'est jusqu'au bout.
On n'abandonne pas un ami
à moitié du chemin.
Vous savez, c'est autorisé,
dans l'islam,
dans nos pays, le divorce,
mais les Afghans le pratiquent pas.
C'est honteux, le divorce.
On fait pas le mariage,
c'est pas facile,
avec quelqu'un qu'on connaît pas,
mais après on fait pas le divorce.
Nous, normalement,
on n'a pas l'habitude
d'abandonner, quitter,
celui qui a fait du bien pour nous,
le laisser à moitié du chemin.
Surtout, c'est pas bon
pour un soldat,
un homme de combat.
C'est hors d'honneur
et hors de question.
On n'aurait pas dû
nous abandonner.
-Comme la manifestation,
c'était complètement inutile,
il n'y avait pas de journaliste,
pas de médias...
La dernière fois, j'ai décidé
d'inviter 2 journalistes français.
Un journaliste de RFI,
et un journaliste de France Presse.
Grâce à ces journalistes,
on a pu médiatiser notre problème.
Quelques jours après,
j'ai réussi, en fait,
à recevoir un message de la part
de l'ambassadeur de France
et nous avons réussi
à obtenir un visa.
Mais pas tous.
Juste certains.
*Musique afghane
...
-Ca, ça passe pas.
Il faut qu'on le coupe, celui-là.
Brouhaha de travaux
...
*Musique afghane
-Ca, c'est la fenêtre, hein.
...
-On dit "la hutte"
ou "la cabane" ?
Quelle est la différence
entre les deux ?
La hutte, H-U-T-T-E,
et la cabane.
Ca veut dire la même chose,
mais je sais pas
pourquoi on n'utilise pas "hutte"
et qu'on utilise "la cabane".
-J'ai eu l'information
à l'ambassade, à Kaboul,
qu'on allait vivre à Laon.
J'ai regardé sur Google Maps.
J'ai vu la cathédrale.
Voilà, c'est tout.
Et les habitants, 26 000 personnes.
C'est ça, l'information.
J'ai quitté ma mère
et j'ai quitté l'Afghanistan,
qui est comme ma mère.
On est très attaché à sa terre.
Quand on est descendus,
débarqués de l'avion,
il y avait un colonel
qui est venu pour nous accueillir,
un colonel de l'armée,
et après on est montés dans des bus.
On est venus ici,
boulevard de Lyon.
Avant, on était tous ensemble
dans un bâtiment
de sous-officiers.
Et il pleuvait,
il faisait froid.
Il y a une dame qui est venue,
c'était une vieille dame.
Elle a dit : "Je sais,
quand on vient
""et qu'il y a rien à la maison,
c'est difficile."
Ils ont ramené
tout ce qu'ils avaient.
-Je suis arrivé en France
le 31 mars 2016.
Si je me trompe pas,
c'était un samedi.
Un samedi, et il pleuvait.
Quelqu'un qui ne sait pas nager,
vous le mettez dans la mer.
"Débrouille-toi."
C'était comme ça.
On est arrivés
devant un immeuble,
les gens nous accueillent,
et on descend avec nos bagages.
Donc la seule chose,
l'avantage qu'on avait,
c'est qu'un appartement
nous attendait, déjà.
Il y avait des chambres.
Il y avait deux chambres,
une grande table,
avec sept chaises
pour sept personnes.
Et sept lits.
Voilà.
On était au centre de la ville,
25 familles,
avec des cultures différentes.
Il y a un qui vient de province,
l'autre qui vient
du centre de Kaboul,
l'autre qui vient du nord,
de l'est...
Avec les enfants,
les vieux,
les vieilles, les jeunes,
les moyens, tous.
A cette époque-là,
donc en 2016,
on était 102 personnes.
-Quand je suis venue ici,
j'habitais dans un appartement.
Quand j'ai vu
les femmes afghanes,
ils ont mis tout le monde
avec des voiles, des burqas,
comme ça,
Sauf moi, que je ne mets pas
de voile,
et je sais pas,
ils m'ont regardée,
et ils ont dit :
"Madame ne met pas de voile,
"comment elle peut sortir
de la maison ?"
J'ai demandé à mon mari,
il m'a dit de ne pas penser à ça,
que chacun avait sa vie,
et que si je voulais pas de voile,
je n'en mettais pas,
et que si j'en voulais un,
j'en mettais un,
que c'était ma décision.
-Il y avait des gens,
des interprètes,
qui sont venus
avec leurs vêtements traditionnels,
au centre de la ville,
et les gens qui nous regardaient
se demandaient
ce qu'il se passait.
Autour de nous,
les gens étaient inquiets.
Vraiment très, très inquiets.
Ils ont peur
d'être vandalisés,
que leurs voitures soient volées
on qu'on leur casse les carreaux.
Un mois après notre arrivée,
on a eu des signes
sur les murs de notre bâtiment.
Là, ils ont fait des signes
comme de Hitler,
des petites choses...
"Rentrez chez vous",
un truc comme ça.
Après, les assistants sociaux,
ils ont nettoyé le jour même.
-Les dessins,
c'était des croix gammées.
-Des croix gammées, oui.
Croix gammées.
Un oiseau crie.
...
-Une fois que je suis arrivé
sur le territoire français,
le travail que Pôle emploi
m'a proposé,
c'était de trier la salade
sur le tapis
à l'entreprise Daunat,
qui se trouve à Laon.
Pourtant, j'ai la capacité
de travailler en génie civil.
J'étais un ingénieur,
j'étais aussi un électricien.
Après, j'ai décidé
de quitter le travail,
et actuellement,
je travaille en qualité d'interprète
pour les immigrants afghans
qui sont déjà venus en France.
-Oui, il a une question, docteur.
Pendant combien de temps
il va rester hospitalisé chez vous ?
Vous allez le libérer
dans combien de temps, docteur ?
*-Il est pas du tout
emprisonné.
S'il s'en va, il s'en va,
on va pas le poursuivre
ni lancer les gendarmes.
Le problème, c'est qu'il a
une forte suspicion de tuberculose,
et le but,
c'est de le protéger lui
et les autres migrants
qui habitent avec lui.
-D'accord, ainsi soit-il.
Il va pas contaminer
d'autres migrants
ou d'autres personnes,
mais il demande votre autorisation
afin de pouvoir partir au camp
et récupérer ses cigarettes,
ses affaires, le téléphone,
et après il revient dans la foulée.
-OK, on lui fait confiance.
Il traduit en pachto.
...
*Propos en pachto
-D'accord, OK.
Il va revenir.
Il est pachtoun,
il est fidèle à la parole donnée,
et il va revenir.
*-Bon, très bien, vous le remerciez
et vous lui dites
qu'on prend soin de lui.
-Ouais, merci, docteur.
Merci de réfléchir à sa santé,
à lui-même,
à une personne qui est venue
clandestinement.
Merci beaucoup.
Musique douce
...
Les perruches crient.
-Est-ce que t'as du jaune ?
-Euh, oui,
c'est moi qui l'avais.
-Je suis en train
de dessiner une abeille.
-J'en rajoute ici et ici.
-Il est encore plus noir.
-Montre-moi. Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
-C'est un arbre.
-Ah, un arbre !
C'est un arbre,
c'était en Afghanistan ?
-Oui.
-C'est bien. Les trucs verts...
-C'est des feuilles.
-Ah, les feuilles de l'arbre.
C'est bien.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
-C'est des voitures.
-Des voitures
qui passent par la route.
-Toi, t'avais
une voiture dorée.
-Dorée, exactement.
J'avais une voiture dorée,
et votre oncle,
il avait une voiture rose,
comme ça.
-Je sais.
-Oh, toi, t'as dessiné
beaucoup de choses.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
-Le drapeau de l'Afghanistan.
-D'accord, c'est le drapeau.
-Ca, j'ai essayé de faire
la robe traditionnelle,
mais après, j'ai pas réussi.
Du coup, j'ai fait un autre truc.
Ca, c'est le truc
qu'on met sur notre tête
avec beaucoup de bijoux dessus.
-Beaucoup de bijoux dessus.
D'accord.
-Et les fleurs,
les poissons.
-Les poissons, oui.
Ca, vous avez bien dessiné,
quand je rentrais de mon travail.
Je m'allongeais et je buvais du thé.
Tu t'en souviens ?
Ca, quand tu étais à la crèche,
t'apprenais l'alphabet en perse.
Ils récitent l'alphabet en perse.
Voilà, ça, c'est l'alphabet.
Super, c'est bien, ça, merci.
Musique douce
...
Propos indistincts
en langue étrangère
...
-Quand j'étais jeune,
j'étais à l'école,
au lycée Esteqlal.
A cette époque,
les femmes se baladaient
toutes seules,
elles étaient en pleine autonomie.
Ma mère faisait ses courses
toute seule.
On allait au cinéma. Il y avait
des cinémas, des théâtres.
...
Les portes
des maisons étaient
presque ouvertes.
On fermait pas le cadenas,
on surveillait même pas,
on dormait tranquillement.
Les policiers n'avaient pas d'armes,
à cette époque.
Ils venaient avec un bâton,
avec un petit bâton,
le bâton qui représentait la loi.
Malheureusement, avec la guerre,
c'est parti, tout s'est fini.
Musique orientale
...
-Quand j'étais jeune,
j'ai pensé que je serais
une présentatrice
à la télé.
Malheureusement, ma famille
ne l'a pas permis.
Ils ont dit : "Non, c'est pas bien
pour les filles."
Ma famille, ils sont...
ouverts,
mais notre...
Notre peuple, il n'est pas ouvert.
Après, j'ai continué mes études
à l'université de Kaboul,
département français,
et j'ai choisi d'être professeure.
Aujourd'hui,
on commence la première
leçon de français.
Ce que je dis,
il faut que vous le répétiez.
C'est une fenêtre, c'est la...
-PORTE.
-Comment t'appelles-tu ?
-Je m'appelle Hajar.
-Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
-Un stylo.
-Prenez votre cahier
et écrivez ce que j'écris.
"Masculin" et "féminin".
...
Ca, c'est le dépliant de quoi ?
-J'ai été
dans le lycée francophone Esteqlal,
parce que j'ai préféré
la langue française
et la civilisation française.
A l'époque de la monarchie,
tous les étudiants de Kaboul,
la majorité, parlaient français.
Les membres du ministère
des Affaires étrangères
étaient francophones.
Notre roi
a voyagé à Paris,
et il a écrit un contrat culturel
avec la France.
-Le fils du roi nous a invités
dans la piscine,
dans un jardin,
en Afghanistan.
Alors, nous avons été
en train de nager,
que le roi vient
avec ses corps d'armées, etc.,
avec ses bodyguards.
Alors, notre corps était nu.
Le roi vient, à chacun,
nous demander des questions
en français,
parce que le roi a fait
ses études en France.
Sa famille a fait
Alors, le roi a demandé
à chacun de ceux qui nageaient.
Il dit :
"Comment s'appelle cet animal ?"
J'ai dit :
"Ce n'est pas un animal,
"c'est un oiseau."
Je lui dis
que ça s'appelle un canard.
Il dit : "Très bien.
"L'eau dans laquelle vous nagez,
comment ça s'appelle ?"
J'ai dit : "Piscine, la piscine."
Il me dit : "Bravo, bravo, bravo."
Après, il a demandé
d'autres questions.
Finalement,
le roi était très content,
et il est retourné
à son palais royal.
-A la veille de son départ
pour la France, sa Majesté
nous a reçus dans son bureau
du palais de Dar ul-Aman.
-Vous savez
qu'il est toujours agréable,
je dis ma joie de retrouver bientôt
la France,
à laquelle tant de souvenirs
m'attachent.
-Pour votre part,
vous avez vécu en France,
vous avez étudié à Paris,
au lycée Janson-de-Sailly,
et à Montpellier, également.
-Oui, mais il y a longtemps
de cela.
35 ans, je crois.
Depuis, comme vous le voyez,
j'ai quelque peu perdu la pratique
de votre belle langue.
Musique douce
...
-Aujourd'hui, il y a une dame
infirmière qui m'a appris un mot,
sans dictionnaire,
c'est "côtes".
Il traduit "côtes".
-Oui, c'est bien ici.
Après, moi aussi,
j'ai appris un mot.
-Quel mot ?
Il rit.
-Un mot : "sporadiquement".
"Sporadiquement".
- "Sporadiquement", d'accord.
-Et "blafard", aussi.
-Quoi ?
-Le mot de "blafard".
-"Blafard", ça, je sais pas,
je connais pas.
-J'ai besoin d'une phrase
en français surcomposée,
à l'imparfait, subjonctif,
passif en même temps.
Subjonctif, passif,
surcomposé,
comment on dit en français ?
-C'est comme ça, le français.
-Avec plus-que-parfait,
passif, subjonctif,
je peux dire
que "j'eusse été aimé", par exemple.
Avec l'imparfait :
"Que je fusse aimé."
Mais avec une phrase surcomposée
dans l'imparfait subjonctif passif
en même temps...
Comment on dit, en français ?
-Indicatif, on va dire...
Ils parlent en langue étrangère.
C'est un dictionnaire mobile, lui,
c'est un dictionnaire.
C'est un dictionnaire.
Musique douce
...
-C'est maman.
Hier, l'après-midi,
on a terminé l'extérieur.
On va passer à l'intérieur.
Voilà.
-On n'a pas fait Paris en un jour.
-Oui, c'est vrai.
On a besoin de temps.
C'est très, très bien.
Un beau travail.
-Travail d'équipe !
Il rit.
-Je vous ai vu à l'oeuvre !
Je retourne chez moi.
-Et voilà.
De 2016 jusqu'à aujourd'hui,
les interprètes,
on a gardé cette liaison.
J'ai discuté, ils disent :
"Oui, avec plaisir, tu choisis
le jour, la date",
et environ 7 ou 8 personnes
m'ont aidées
pour construire cette cabane.
Après, ici,
on peut passer le temps,
avec ma famille,
avec nos collègues
qui viennent souvent ici,
pour faire un barbecue,
pour prendre un thé, un café.
Ca, c'est vraiment...
Le jardin,
c'est moi qui l'ai fait,
mais les 25 familles
qui sont à côté de nous
sont très contentes.
Musique de fanfare
...
-J'ai monté
mon dossier de naturalisation.
J'ai envoyé deux fois,
trois fois, quatre fois...
La sixième fois,
j'ai renvoyé, mais pas de retour.
-Je suis en train de préparer
les papiers, mais j'ai peur,
parce que si je fais
une demande,
s'ils me refusent,
ça, c'est triste.
-C'est la préfecture
qui nous a accordé
la carte de séjour.
La différence, c'est ça.
Avec une carte de séjour,
on peut rentrer en Afghanistan
et on peut retourner en France.
Avec un statut de réfugié,
on n'a pas le droit
d'aller en Afghanistan.
On a le droit d'aller
dans des pays européens,
mais pas en Afghanistan.
J'ai juste une carte
d'ancien combattant,
donnée par l'Onac,
le service des anciens combattants,
comme quoi j'ai bien servi
l'armée française.
C'est pour ça que, régulièrement,
on est invités
à la préfecture,
pendant la cérémonie.
Voilà, pendant la cérémonie,
le festival, le 14 juillet.
Musique calme
...
-Thérèse, elle est
obligée d'obéir
à la famille de son mari.
Elle reste à la maison.
Moi, j'ai pensé aux femmes
qui habitaient en Afghanistan.
C'est à cause de ça
que j'ai traduit ce livre.
Dès que les Talibans
sont arrivés à Kaboul,
c'est fini.
L'avenir pour les femmes,
Seulement les filles
qui ont déjà 12 ans,
jusqu'à 12 ans, 13 ans,
elles peuvent aller à l'école.
Après 13 ans, 14 ans ou 15 ans,
c'est fini.
L'Afghanistan,
c'est une prison
pour les femmes,
avec des cages,
avec des grilles.
Un journal télévisé
passe en fond.
...
-Moi, j'aime pas les Talibans.
Ils n'ont pas le droit de fermer
les écoles des filles.
C'est pas l'islam,
c'est pas l'islam.
Si vous envoyez un garçon
dans une école,
au bout d'un moment,
vous allez former une personne.
Si vous scolarisez une fille,
vous scolarisez une famille.
Les fermetures d'écoles...
La richesse d'une communauté,
ce n'est pas les mines,
c'est le cerveau, en fait,
le talent, la scolarité.
-J'ai eu l'espoir
de retourner un jour en Afghanistan.
Je pensais que, peut-être,
les talibans, ce serait fini,
qu'il n'y aurait plus
d'autres problèmes de sécurité.
Malheureusement,
vous voyez que les talibans
se sont emparés du pouvoir,
et nous ne pouvons pas rentrer
en Afghanistan.
-L'Afghanistan est situé...
C'est un point neutre
entre l'Occident et l'Orient,
la zone sous l'influence
des Russes,
et la zone sous l'influence
de l'ex-empire britannique
et les Américains.
Il y en a un qui avance,
le 2e recule.
Le 2e avance,
le 3e recule.
Donc, depuis des siècles,
il y a la guerre.
Il y a des générations
qui sont sacrifiées.
Ca va continuer.
Jusqu'à quand ?
On ne sait pas.
Ils s'expriment en langue étrangère.
...
-Quelle est la valeur d'amour
pour un fou,
s'il n'est pas tombé amoureux ?
-OK...
...
Il n'a pas dansé
autour de la flamme.
-Il n'y a pas de "il".
-Il n'a pas dansé
autour de la flamme...
Il ne sait pas la valeur de l'amour.
-Non, mais...
-Tu parles de qui ?
-Je parle de toi !
Non, je parle de toi,
je parle avec toi,
il n'y a pas de "il".
Il n'y a pas de "elle" ni de "il",
je parle avec toi.
-La poésie,
ça ne donne pas le même sens.
-Maintenant, vous avez compris
le sentiment de ce poème, ou pas ?
Au niveau de la traduction,
vous avez compris ou pas,
ce qu'il a dit ?
-Ca veut dire qu'une personne
qui est folle et idiote,
elle ne comprend pas
la valeur de l'amour,
s'il est tombé amoureux.
Comme un papillon
qui tourne autour de la flamme...
Autour de la flamme.
-Pourquoi il fait le tour ?
-Parce qu'il est amoureux.
-Amoureux de quoi ?
-Amoureux de la flamme.
-Voilà. Pour ça.
Il est tombé amoureux de la flamme.
Pour ça, il brûle.
Voilà.
-Mes quatre soeurs, actuellement,
qui habitent en Afghanistan,
mon frère qui habite en Afghanistan,
la famille de mon épouse,
les frères, les soeurs,
les hommes, tous ceux
qui habitent en Afghanistan,
ils sont en danger.
-J'ai fait une demande de protection
aussi pour ma famille,
à la cellule de crise du ministère
des Affaires étrangères.
Malheureusement, je n'ai reçu
aucune réponse favorable.
Moi, je me sens aussi comme ça :
depuis que la guerre a commencé
en Ukraine,
la communauté internationale
a oublié, en fait, l'Afghanistan.
...
-Merci.
C'est un peu safrané.
...
-La plupart des femmes
des interprètes
sur lesquels on fait le film,
elles se cachent,
ne souhaitent pas être filmées.
Est-ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer ?
-Euh...
La plupart des femmes ont gardé
leur culture.
En région, les femmes ne parlent pas
avec les hommes étrangers,
avec les hommes.
Je pense que maintenant aussi,
elles n'osent pas,
mais j'espère
que petit à petit,
elles commencent
à un peu... sortir,
à apprendre la langue...
Jingle de la SNCF
-En tant que père, je suis
très, très fier que mes enfants,
qui ne parlaient même pas
cette langue,
la langue française,
soient arrivés à avoir leur bac,
s'inscrire à la fac...
Après, c'est eux qui décident,
s'ils veulent rester ici avec nous
ou s'ils partent.
Pour l'instant,
ils sont sur la bonne route.
Des cloches sonnent.
...
Détonations
Musique douce
...
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA